friday at first light just beyond
ukraine's northern border with russia
firefighters tackling a blaze at a fuel
depot in the russian city of belgorod
the governor there has accused ukraine
of sending helicopters to attack the oil
storage tanks under the cover of
darkness
security camera and other footage on
social media seems to confirm some kind
of attack by helicopters and the firing
of missiles
if the russian claims are true this
would be the first attack by ukrainian
forces on russian soil since the war
began ukraine's foreign minister said he
could neither confirm nor deny
responsibility but the kremlin says the
suspected airstrike doesn't help the
prospect of ongoing peace talks
ukraine's top security official later
denied his country was behind the attack
russia has continued to withdraw units
from towns and cities north of the
capital kiev
the partial withdrawal of units of the
russian occupation forces from the north
of kiev region towards the state border
with the republic of belarus continues
one of those battlefields has been the
airport and military base at hostamel to
the northwest of kiev
drone footage shows the air base heavily
damaged but the russians gone russian
forces had seized the base in the
opening hours of the war but were forced
back by ukrainian counter-attack before
recapturing it again later
the ukrainians accused the russians of
indiscriminate shelling to cover their
withdrawal and launching multiple
missile attacks
[Applause]
what does it mean scaling down combat
actions in cave and turning directions
does it mean that there will be 100
rockets instead of 200 rockets launching
kiev or something else
on the southern front following long and
complex negotiations between the two
warring sides and the international
committee of the red cross a convoy of
buses was sent to the besieged city of
mariupol in the hope of evacuating
trapped residents
this is lucy from the icrc we are
currently on the move from zappos to go
to mario paul in order to
ensure safe passage for the civilians
who desperately want to flee the city
the icrc is also looking to bring much
needed humanitarian aid into the city
rob mcbride al jazeera level